- J'ai toujours cultivé
ma naiveté, j'ai jamais voulu
développer du cynisme...
- C'est un monument de
la pensée, qui nous a quittés
aujourd'hui. Serge Bouchard
est mort à 73 ans d'un arrêt
cardiaque. Claude Mailhot était
son ami depuis plus de 60 ans.
CLAUDE MAILHOT
animateur de télévision
- Vous avez parfaitement raison,
c'est un monument, c'est
une des rischesse du Québec
et vous allez dire que je suis
pas objectif parce que c'est
mon grand ami, mais c'est
un bonhomme brillant.
- Avec des émission de radio
comme "De remarquables oubliés",
"Une épinette noire nommée
Diesel" et "Les chemins
de travers", Serge Bouchard
a partagé ses réflexions
pendant plus de 25 ans
et parcouru le pays d'un bout
à l'autre pour donnner
des conférences.
LAURENT TURCOT, historien
- Non, le savoir n'existait pas
en vase clos. Serge, ce qu'il
voulait faire c'est ouvrir
et chaque fois il disait :
"On est capable de l'expliquer
simplement".
- Diplômé des universités Laval
et McGill, Serge Bouchard avait
étudié le savoir des chasseurs
innus du Labrador et la culture
des camionneurs du nord
du Canada.
- C'est les artistes de
l'embrayage. Savoir embrayer.
RACHEL VERDON, réalisatrice
- C'est cette espèce de regard
d'enfant, mais aussi c'est
un humain qui parle toujours
à l'autre comme un humain,
JEAN-PHILIPPE PLEAU, réalisateur
animateur et sociologue
- J'ai un mot en tête
c'est "bienveillance".
Vraiment, la bienveillance
à l'égard des communauté
autochtones, des camionneurs,
de tous les collègues qu'il a
côtoyés. Chaque personne
en valait la peine, pour Serge.
- Les réactions à son décès
ont été nombreuses. Toute
la classe politique a souligné
le départ d'un grand sage.
FRANÇOIS LEGAULT
premier ministre du Québec
- Le Québec perd quelqu'un
qui a analysé notre société
sous toutes les couture au cours
des dernières années, et qui
était un excellent auteur.
- Au cours de sa carrière il a
publié une vingtaine de livres,
remportant plusieurs distictions
dont le titre d'officier de
l'Ordre national du Québec.
Serge Bouchard avait perdu sa
deuxième femme et collaboratrice
Marie-Christine Lévesque,
à la fin de l'an dernier,
d'une tumeur au cerveau.
Il lui avait d'ailleurs consacré
le livre: "Un café avec Marie".
- C'est très, très dur de faire
des deuils, de s'assoir.
Et en temps de pandémie,
c'est 10 fois pire.
- Aujourd'hui le Québec
pleure la disparition d'un grand
penseur qui a su partager
son amour de la connaissance.
- Je l'ai perdu, je l'ai perdu
physiquement, mais il sera
toujours là parce que ses livres
je les ai côté de moi et
je relis de passages, des fois,
c'est tellement brillant
ce qu'il écrivait.
- Mais un temps dur qui
est cruel, c'est le temps
de l'univers, c'est le temps
universel. Il passe. Et il est
irréversible, et il n'a
qu'un sens. C'est bien maudit.
- Ici Nabi-Alexandre Chartier,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.